one of the best uh writers and
interviewers and chroniclers and putting
it all on paper in the business he's got
uh a book coming out in short order in
october i believe you can pre-order it
right now about the new england patriots
it's better to be feared the new england
patriots dynasty and the pursuit of
greatness but part of the reason why
we're having them on is just a terrific
interview with matthew stafford um for
the espn cover story seth wickersham
back here on the show how are you seth
i'm good man how are you i'm doing fine
i've i got to tell you you had me at
hello with the stafford uh interview
and and and the way that you tweeted it
out
i mean this is what def look i i always
enjoy your your your work but i
definitely clicked
on the the line that you said is what is
it like to do something professionally
for 12 years but yet
not know just how good you're at you are
at it i mean that one really hit me the
staff would really not know how good he
is at football right now seth i i mean i
think that he has a lot of confidence
but
you know he
he wanted out of detroit for one reason
and that's because you know for twelve
years all except for three of those
twelve years he was at home during the
playoffs
and football is and always will be a
late january and early february game
and for most of you know nine out of
those twelve years he watched other
quarterbacks
you know author their legend
um while he was at home
and
i asked him at one point i was like what
do you want out of the rest your career
and he was all he was at an autograph
signing um and he he put down the pen
and he looked at me he said you know i
just want to play in big games
i just want to make big throws
against the top competition
when everyone is watching rather than
just like a one o'clock game you know
during the regular season
and i find that a really earnest and a
really humble
desire and answer on his part and the
other part of that is that you know he
doesn't know how he's gonna perform
for the entire time he was in detroit he
was
everything was on his shoulders and now
it's a little bit different you know
rather than see
what his skill set can transcend he's
the missing piece on a team that's
expected
at least internally i mean it's super
bowl or nothing for them
and
matthew doesn't know how he's going to
perform on that stage and i think he's
really eager he's desperately eager
to see what happens so what did you
glean from him as to why
he finally
you know either mustered up the gumption
or
had enough of what he was dealing with
in detroit to ask for his
way out to finally just flat out go to
ownership and say let's do this
it was really interesting because you
know a lot of players a lot of
professional athletes as you know
derive a lot of power and pride from
kind of you know sticking it to their
employer
and
with stafford it was the complete
opposite he was almost embarrassed about
it he
the regular season ended with a loss to
the vikings it was another wasted season
he knew that there was going to be
another rebuild with a new gm and a new
head coach
and you know even matthew even though
matthew stafford was the franchise in
detroit
each time there's a regime change he has
to kind of find his way you know what
what's required of him what kind of
leader does he have to be in the
building
and i don't think that he felt like he
could do it and so the night after that
lost the vikings he told his wife kelly
something that they had discussed before
the season and that was asking out and
um he said i was gonna do it i'm gonna
do it tomorrow i'm gonna ask for trade
and then the next morning she enters
their kitchen and he's emptying the
dishwasher
and he's quiet and he's carrying on an
entire conversation with himself in his
own head where he is reconsidering and
doubting his decision because in a very
real way
he looked at it like a failure if he was
going to ask out you know he came to
detroit in 2009 when both the lions were
owen 16 and the city were at its lowest
and he wanted to deliver a championship
there
and
asking out would be kind of an epic
concession but you know by the time he
left his house that morning he stopped
by and he said to his wife you know
say a little prayer for me because he
decided to go ahead and do it and he
actually cried during that meeting
all right tell me more
[Laughter]
keep going
well i i think that he the other thing
that was interesting i found about it is
that
you know he wanted it quiet
and he was incredibly nervous he did not
want to play the leak game against the
lions like even though the lions had
been kind of a mess throughout most of
his career there some of his best
friends were there they had paid him a
ton of money the team had helped his
wife when she needed that tumor removed
from her brain years ago
and
you know he liked his teammates a lot
and
so after he asked for the trade the
teams caught a little off guard by it
but after they hire a head coach in a gm
they decide to proceed with it and he's
nervous
and he's just having a hard time with
this decision like
everything about it was just eating him
up finally his wife says
we gotta get out of the country we gotta
get out of here like
we need to do something different so
they decide to get away to cabo for a
quick weekend he lands in cabo when he
texas friend andrew whitworth who just
happens to be
the
um offensive tackle for the rams
and he says hey i'm here
woodworth texas head coach sean mcveigh
who just happens to be in cabo also
and within an hour they're at a pool
with cocktails
and the next thing you know sean mcvay
and matthew stafford are off to the side
talking football
while you know everybody else is kind of
mingling and it was really interesting
because sean mcvay got down there he's
obviously not in a great place they're
thinking about moving on from jared goff
right
and he's down there with his fiance
after a long season they had just lost
the packers in the playoffs
and sean mcveigh
texts the rams brass and he says you're
not going to effing believe this matthew
stafford is here
they meet at the pool
they bond
the next day sean mcvay is in his room
on vacation watching cut-ups of matthew
stafford on his phone and on his ipad
testing the patience of his fiancee
veronica or one could argue investing in
their mutual future happiness
later matthew stafford is iran
so okay
based on on all of what you just said
he
has this moment with his wife where he's
just like okay we were talking about it
i'm gonna do it yep the it being
going to the lions to say i i want out
he does it in a tear-filled emotional
uh meeting
that was that would with sheila
fordham president yeah ownership okay so
and so um
he he does that
they start the process
i guess right away
during which time he and his wife say
we're getting out of the country
the rams left tackle and coach just
happens to be there
and then a trade happens while he's
there that happened that happened
in the in on planet earth
wow
that's crazy you know like drew brees
was in cabo at the same time kyle
shanahan was in cabo and that too and
that too seth because so many people
seth wickersham here on the rich eisen
show from espn phenomenal article and um
a chat with with matthew stafford that
we're chopping up right now so that's
the thing that i i i point out to
everybody if they need it because the
the
doubters about stafford
is just oh he that le the guy from the
lions who made a ton of money and
amassed all these yards and didn't
amount to anything that
the number of people who are so upset in
the nfl that the rams got stafford
before them
includes kyle shanahan of the niners he
absolutely that was part of this off
season that a lot of folks glossed over
because obviously they have trey lance
now and that whole lance garoppolo thing
is still playing out as you and i are
talking
that that was seemingly a plan a as
opposed to trading draft choices to go
up and get a third overall selection
yeah i mean from the moment this season
ended the 49ers were in the quarterback
derby and i think that
um i don't think that it's exactly
related but i do think that matthew
stafford is one of the re going to the
rams is one of the reasons
that the 49ers decided to trade up to
draft trade lance and you know i i was
saying
you know usually if you know you get
great lead gossip you know at the bars
at the combine we're at the bar at the
owners meetings and i'm going to
seriously lobby my boss to just send me
to cabo after the season ends and i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna post it by the
pool and let things happen
because that's clearly the epicenter of
power in the nfl that nobody else is at
yes indeed some people just go there to
get hammered you know what i mean
you know
you're going to go there for work
because it clearly you can get some work
done there seth wickersham here on the
rich eisen show so
you know the two words i thought would
be factored into part of the process of
doing all this that i guess wasn't
because the decision you said that
stafford and his wife made was right
after the regular season was watching
tom brady ascend to the throne in
another spot that brady's you know
decision to say there's some way other
way for me to be happy and do something
after 20 years of something even though
it's incredibly successful six super
bowls in the 20 years of doing something
he decides to do something else and that
inspires so many others like rogers and
and russell wilson have thoughts of
wanderlust
that had nothing to do with stafford's
decision making brady
you know i don't i think that it
couldn't help but do it but you know
brady had way more control over his
situation than stafford did i mean
stafford didn't even have a no trade
clause he was kind of at the mercy of
the lions and you know the panthers were
heavily interested in stafford he didn't
want to go there and the lions kind of
did him a solid by dealing him to l.a um
you know brady was a free agent
obviously it's you know it's a different
situation but you know his name came up
when i was with matthew because
you need you played a little bit in your
interview with him earlier you know he
picking up this new playbook is hard and
because as he told me
you know
you not only have to learn something new
you have to forget something else and he
thought it was really interesting the
tom brady came out and said you know
midway through last season i was still
struggling to call plays
in bruce aryan's offense because um you
know he'd been in one system his entire
life and where stafford's been in a
couple it's still hard to
learn that new playbook and get down
cold especially when people are looking
at you for answers people as he said in
your interview have been in that system
for years and i got to watch that a
little bit and i thought that was really
fascinating like i
i was with him in cooper cup and they
were talking about various signals
that
stafford had given for route combination
to practice that day
and
you know stafford was kind of fact
checking his process with cup and that
was really interesting like i'd never
seen a quarterback do that with a
receiver before
and in terms of brady let's uh
transition to the next reason why you're
probably going to be on a show like this
one
other than my inviting you beforehand if
you wish i love it it's better to be
feared by seth wickersham the new
england patriots dynasty and the pursuit
of greatness
what are we going to learn can you drop
a nugget i know that you want to
probably save everything for when the
book drops as the kids say on october
12th
but what are we gonna learn what what
can you tell us
you know i i i i i won't get into
details yet but like i do think that
like you know one of the interesting
things is that um
you know i i that i sort of
have known tom brady and bill belichick
for my entire career and for a lot of
that career i had you know i was in tom
brady's apartment i was at his private
super bowl parties i was getting you
know getting on the phone with belichick
to talk about things late at night you
know after he had finished his work day
and it was a interesting journalism
lesson to never throw away a notebook
because
i was able to tap into a lot of that
stuff from you know the early part of
the dynasty
and combine it with
you know reporting based on those teams
based on the subsequent 10 years when
they didn't win the championship when
they you know were just close and were
kind of plateaued at that highest
plateau
and then the second half of it where
they won three more
and then it finally kind of
disintegrated and um
you know
i do my very best to bring you you know
inside those guys personalities inside
how decisions were made what it was like
to work in that building
and you know how their greatness was
achieved and and what some of the cost
of that greatness were
why did it have to end
i think tom wanted out and i think that
coach belichick
had determined that i think that he was
okay with tom moving on i think that you
know at the end of the day
look if if the patriots had signed tom
brady to a five-year contract like he
wanted after
they beat the falcons after they had had
five super bowls
so much of the subsequent drama might
have been averted but instead you know
your belichick you want to hang on to
garoppolo and see how that played out
and you had brady who wanted a
commitment until he was age 45 and the
patriots were just never really willing
to give him that commitment
and i think that these are all
incredibly obsessive competitive people
and
you know by the end i think they had all
just had enough of each other
do we do you get into the garoppolo
stuff in your book you got that oh yeah
oh yeah so um because you know the word
is that tom's like get him out of here
and bill didn't really want to and had
to and that's how jimmy g winds up as a
a niner for just a second-round pick
and you know
because i mean jimmy g you know was on
the patriots radar
only a couple months ago right before
the draft also right um you know
i think bill belichick has always wanted
to leave the patriots whenever he walks
away he's always want to leave them
leave the team in a good place you know
you have bill walsh you he walked away
from the 49ers when they won a super
bowl
and you know george seifert took it over
and i think that walsh you know secretly
kind of wanted the team to fail without
him instead they go whatever fourteen
and two and blow out the broncos in the
super bowl one of the greatest teams
ever with this rookie head coach and i
think that bill belichick has always had
way more pride
than to you know walk away and have the
thing collapse when he does leave and i
think that a huge piece of that
was having the team set up long-term at
quarterback and you know for a while he
was deeply invested in garoppolo
so um before i let you go seth
wickersham um knowing belichick and
covering him as as you have
the fact that he's got a quarterback
decision to make in a training camp with
a first-round drafted guy
this is potentially kind of new for him
knowing him and knowing the history of
him and what he's been done can any of
that inform you as to what decision you
might make over the next two weeks as to
who's his starter for the 2021 season
look i think they wanted to be really
patient with mack jones um
but
this latest episode with cam and being
out most of this week you know i i have
no insight into how that's going to
affect things it'll be interesting if it
does
um you know the team not only wants to
be patient with mac jones but they've
clearly been very patient with cam
newton
and it'll be interesting to see if they
lean on cam
and hope that he can perform well to get
them through that game against tampa you
know again i have no insight on this but
you imagine starting a rookie
quarterback against tom brady
with all that hype swirling around that
game if
yeah but if anybody could handle it's a
guy who's played for nick saban for
alabama i mean
i i understand brady coming back to new
england is uh
a unicorn of a scheduled game on a
sunday night with a whole country
coming up to see but why not i mean why
not start the kid wearing brady's
um brady's college number
and tb12 coming back in and wouldn't
this be the way i mean honestly if
bill's going to start the guy's getting
best chance to win just like he starts
jonas gray one week and then doesn't
forever more right because he he's going
to go with whoever might match up best
on most positions but
don't you think
deep down harder hearts
having the kid
be the one to beat brady as opposed to
cam i mean wouldn't that be just well
the way to go yeah i mean i think you
you were you hit it right on there um
you know if it gives them the best
chance to win and um you know we'll just
see how it happens like i said i mean i
think they wanted to be patient with mac
jones
and you know we'll see whether the
the events of the past week end up
impacting that and how it's impacted as
the season begins well we all know seth
that um the guy who wears moe lewis's
number right now cj mosley in a week two
game jets versus the patriots he'll
knock uh cam out and then the mac jones
dynasty will begin that's what's gonna
happen in week two just like uh 2001.
same thing the poor guy almost died man
no i understand that but he's okay now
so you know
that's that's that old uh crimes and
misdemeanors line that comedy is tragedy
plus time seth so
it's been long enough it's 20 years my
gosh uh thanks for the time uh look for
my number certainly uh as your book's
coming out i can't wait to read it look
forward to it i will thank you so much
everybody should read the matthew
stafford article written by this man and
it's better to be feared which is
available for
purchase right now the new england
patriots down to see seth wickersham
here on the program
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here